Um,
Miguel [inaudible] died in Madrid on April 23rd,
16,
16.
Remember that famously Shakespeare died on the same date,
not the same day because England and Spain were following different calendars,
a difference of two or three days in the last five years of his life.
So Avantis so published the exemplary novels in 16,
13.
The voyeurs to Parnassus,
which is a long poem of essentially literary criticism where he reviews,
uh,
the writers of the,
of the period,
uh,
that appeared in 16,
14,
uh,
part two of the Quixote appeared in 1615.
And also in that year,
his volume of theater called eight place and eight new interludes never before
performed in 16,
17.
The trials of policies and see he's moon that was published posthumously,
those place he was able to,
uh,
to publish because of his,
newly acquired fame.
And,
uh,
also,
because they had not been a very successful on the stage except for the
interludes.
Uh,
let me,
uh,
repeat a quotation from the casebook
pacifically from the,
uh,
biographical essay by Manuel [inaudible] that opens the case book that I,
this is a quote that I have read before,
but I want to repeat it.
It is a quote that also has embedded a statement by Ann Hill del Rio,
which I'm a,
I think you may,
uh,
remember his name then he case.
And there's a real,
uh,
that I think,
our,
uh,
appropriate,
as we wind up our course.
But before I read you that quote,
let me read you the following also by,
uh,
by Doolan
quote,
Cervantes died in Madrid on April 23rd,
16,
16 at peace with himself and with the world at peace with himself and with the
world having received the last sacraments and was buried in the convent of the
Trinitarian nuns.
He died without bitterness or regrets since he had been fully conscious of his
merit,
indeed,
of his genius,
and was aware that his creations would endure.
The writer cannot hope for a greater source of consolation,
uh,
later constructions and reconstructions of the building.
Uh,
by the way,
led to the disappearance of savant thisis bones.
So we don't have Cervantes relics.
His bones up lost.
I have been insisting on advantages,
uh,
knowledge of Don Quixote's,
belonging awareness of Don Quixote belonging to the gallery of great literary
figures from the classical past.
And most recently when in the last lecture I spoke about that,
uh,
seen in the last,
in where they lodge.
And there are some wall hangings with,
uh,
with the figures of Helen,
of Troy and Dido.
Uh,
and,
and sanctuary makes the,
uh,
the quip that,
they will be images of,
of themselves,
I think Quixote on sanctuary or everywhere in the future.
And I underline that that is a bet that central has certainly worn.
Now let me go to that longer quote by,
uh,
Duran and del Rio,
who was del Rio was the author of an excellent history of Spanish literature.
And as I said,
he taught for many years at Columbia University.
He was a Spaniard,
objectively says Duran Cervantes.
His life was not a success story.
He was seldom in full control.
He was too poor for many years.
He lacked public recognition.
Yet as Ang Hill del Rio points out,
there is no reason to lament.
I'm quoting now.
Uh,
the young had Valerie or quote,
uh,
we think do rounds quote,
there is no reason to lament servant.
This is misfortunes nor the mediocrity of his daily life.
He could lost,
though he could those through an experience which is seldom sell an obtain,
uh,
when the writer is successful and wealthy,
he could know,
observe,
and feel the beat of Spanish life in its greatness and in its poverty in it
heroic fantasy.
And in the sad reality of an imminent decadence,
he was to leave in his books the most faithful image of this life reflected in
multiple perspectives with bitter sweet irony and penetrating humor.
Uh,
the,
uh,
Ellucian to decadence here is that for many years in the 20th century,
scholars studied the decadence of the Spanish and Pire.
Remember that quote,
uh,
that I brought on?
You must have read as you read earlier from Elliott about Cervantes straddling
those two moments of Spanish history.
One of,
of,
uh,
of great,
triumph,
uh,
and then the beginnings of the decline.
Um,
now Cervantes never attained in his time the recognition of Lopi the vigor that
rider have mentioned,
uh,
so many times,
Lobelia Invega whom said,
Randy's criticized and admired at the same time,
uh,
but Cervantes was a greater writer than Lopi.
And history has confirmed this fact
though Lopez deserves a place in the western cannon.
He should not be at the same level as a set around this.
I say that because Lopez generally,
uh,
not very well known in the English speaking world,
and he sort of,
I don't think he's even appears in my good friend [inaudible] blooms,
uh,
the western cannon.
Uh,
but that is not Lopez fault.
That is Harold fought
Lopei Lopei never created it.
Figure of universal appeal like Don Quixote,
even if he wrote hundreds of place,
perhaps your thousand place.
Many among those plays are masterpieces,
frontier by Huna and [inaudible] and so forth.
Uh,
they,
they're masterpieces in their own right.
And Lopa created thousands of characters.
This is all true,
but he was not on the level of Cervantes.
Ironically,
of course,
in the period Lopa was tremendously successful historically is really a success
story.
He was,
he was rich.
He had,
uh,
a great following.
Uh,
and,
uh,
even his name was synonymous with being good.
If you said they Lopez,
it means it's something is good.
So that's how successful he was.
Uh,
he was just Lord it over the Spanish literary landscape.
But in,
in the early 17th century,
uh,
he fought in the Spanish armada.
He had many women,
mistresses,
wives,
10,
15 children,
some of them legitimate.
And,
uh,
at the end of his life,
he became a priest,
impregnated one of his ministers is really,
uh,
a life really worth a movie.
In the meantime,
said,
Lantus was chugging along,
uh,
in,
in Madrid,
within blocks of each other in Madrid.
Uh,
and,
but he was creating a work that was superior,
uh,
to,
to Lopez.
No,
the question to ask us,
we draw a balance at the end of the course.
Easy set of volunteers who would have deserved such recognition.
Eh,
if he had not written dicky hope there,
but everything else that he wrote,
uh,
w w would we have a such high regard for Cervantes if he had,
only published the rest of his work,
some of which I mentioned when I was listing the books that he published towards
the end of its life.
The answer has to be no.
Uh,
not by far though he would have been acknowledged as an important writer of
short novels on the basis of the exemplary novels.
Nobody last Ame Pladis I'll talk about that later.
He was also the author of a Mediocre Pastoral Romance Gal out there.
Remember that?
He mentions it in the,
he has the characters mentioned it in the scrutiny of the books and he himself
has some critical things to say about that pastor pastoral romance.
And it's still towards the end of his life.
Uh,
in the very last year,
he was still thinking of writing a second part of a gal out there,
but it was a mediocre work with flashes of brilliance that announced the
Quixote.
But that are important because of that,
not in themselves.
Uh,
he was also the author of that very uneven and very ambitious Byzantine romance
called the trials of Perseus.
And see he's wound,
I put this on the boards are all times,
so I don't have to do it.
Uh,
uh,
again,
this is a very odd work as Byzantine romance tend to be and said,
uh,
thought he was deluded into thinking that this was going to be the culmination
of his work,
his best work when he was wrong.
Authors are often wrong about the worth of what they have,
what they write.
And he certainly was wrong about this.
Uh,
the book is,
is missing most of the qualities that we admire in the Quixote.
It's a very long book.
Uh,
it lacks a central figure as compelling as the mat at night,
except for some episodes in Spain that have sort of a realistic cast.
The geography is strange and abstract.
It begins in the,
in the,
uh,
in the snow and ice bound,
regions of a,
of the North Pole and finishes in Rome.
Of course,
uh,
the,
the dialogues are stilted.
They're not like the dialogues and Nikki halt.
They were a Santo speaks in his,
a very folksy way.
Uh,
and it is a very digressive novel.
It has,
uh,
again,
because of this was the author of the copter,
some,
uh,
moments that,
that we see as being brilliant and some hard,
uh,
things that,
for instance,
the characters carry around a banner like painting depicting their adventures so
that whenever somebody asks them where they have been to use,
unfurl this a banner and there is the,
there's their adventures.
It's very funny that way.
It has moments like that,
um,
again,
but as we've got up there,
they better see lists is important because it was written by the author of the
Quixote as a playwright said,
was a master in the comic one act interludes,
the [inaudible] that I have spoken about,
which show many,
uh,
features in common with the Quixote,
particularly,
uh,
the funny parts of it,
the whole day,
the slapstick parts of the Quixote.
Uh,
but his place,
we're stiff neoclassical because Cervantes followed the rules.
Uh,
the,
uh,
that the,
the precip testers,
those who had read Aristotle's poetics where,
uh,
promoting at the time you remember the discussions among the characters.
I think it's chapter 48 of part one.
Uh,
especially,
uh,
involving the Canon of Tolayo about the plays being written at the time where,
where Cervantes through his characters is curious as him,
if before not following those rules he did and then he's,
he's placed,
where does that were just,
uh,
some are okay,
but they're not that good.
Uh,
it is one of those ironies of literary history that Cervantes who was so wildly
imaginative and daring in prose fiction was so timid and conservative when it
came to the theater and mystery.
This is why you cannot just a list authors is you have works.
You have to elicit works.
Uh,
when you are making a hit parade like the one,
uh,
Harold bloom makes him the western cannon.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the high point of Servantez production other than Nikki hoed,
there was exemplary novels or stories as they're called in the translation that
you are using.
This is a terminological problem that I have explained before.
Uh,
the word novella that we have in Spanish were normal today did not exist.
Then.
A Novella,
uh,
was a new,
well that is a short novel or a long short story like the ones we have read and
think on NT Cortadito the glass,
uh,
graduate and the ones that are included in part one of the cohort.
And he said he novellas a Pladis.
Uh,
some of these short novels are true masterpieces of the John and can stand next
to the greatest,
uh,
stories by Cervantes Italian,
predecessors,
of course,
Giovanni Boccaccio,
whom I have mentioned many times and Mattel bundle whom I have also mentioned
before.
Uh,
now,
uh,
I have mentioned them when we discussed some of these novels.
Uh,
Ma,
namely the glass graduate under [inaudible].
Today I'm going to speak about the deceitful marriage and the dog's colloquy.
Uh,
two connected normals that wind up the volume of the exemplary novelists or
exemplary stories.
I have trouble saying an exemplary stories because it's just not stories,
his novels or short novels.
So I may waver,
but you know what I mean?
It's no way less him Paris in Spanish,
not exemplary stories.
Now,
uh,
as we approached these two novel,
if we have to return to the picaresque now,
let me summarize the reasons why the picker escrow is so important in the
development of prose fiction and repeat myself a,
unless you think that I am arbitrarily obsessed with this kind of literature,
it's just that it is truly very important for the development of the novel.
Um,
now in the picker rest there is for the first time,
except for Sally Stina,
but sell it.
Tina was a dialogue,
a dramatic dialogue.
It was not a story with a narrator and so forth.
So,
uh,
in the picker ask this for the first time,
the representation of everyday life and common people with an emphasis on poor
people engaged in the struggle for existence in eh,
Eh,
in a setting that is contemporaneous with the author and the reader.
Uh,
both the author and the reader recognize the setting as being their own is
depressant.
That is no fancy faraway geography.
As in the romances of chivalry or the Byzantine Romances,
there is no remote time,
like the magical time of fantastic stories.
Uh,
the picaresque novels take place in the here and now.
The protagonist is no hero by conventional standards,
literary standards.
Uh,
on the contrary,
he or she,
because there are feminine picker risks and we are going to be talking about one
today is a minor criminal in trouble with the law.
Uh,
and in fact,
the central conceit of novels like glossary [inaudible] is that the text is a
confession or deposition addressed by the accused delinquent to a figure,
uh,
in authority.
So the picker esque is an indictment of society written in the form of the legal
documents used by the authorities do a Mesh,
the Picato in the net of the law.
We saw how don Quixote on Sangio themselves are fugitives from justice and are
finally apprehended.
But by the trooper of the Holy Brotherhood,
that funny trooper of the holy brother who cannot read very well,
if you remember that hilarious scene from part one,
the picker risk makes possible for the novel to Depict Contemporary Society and
common social types.
So just the ones,
uh,
appearing and acquiring relevance in the 16th and 17th century as there is the
beginnings of what is a leveling of society that is moving towards the 18th
century,
the 19th century on revolutions and so forth that we are very familiar with.
So these characters begin to appear in novels as well as in paintings.
If you remember the paintings by we'll ask is that we have looked at during the
semester,
Rafael [inaudible] who might have mentioned before,
but I want to mention again,
uh,
fired Sally.
Yes,
a brilliant,
a Spanish criminologist of the late 19th and early 20th century,
claimed that the picaresque was the origin of the social sciences,
specifically sociology and criminology.
That is sociology and criminology find their source in these kinds of novels.
It's kinds of picker as novels that depict the lower strata of society in,
in,
in great detail.
He includes Cervantes,
his work among,
uh,
those,
works that he,
uh,
places at the origin of the social sciences.
So
it is to me,
very suggestive then that's Advantis chose to wind up his volume of exemplary
novels with these two stories in the picaresque style.
Not picaresque per se,
because Atlanta's never wrote a picaresque novel in the strict sense,
but number who,
the picaresque ambiance and cast of characters.
Remember this is a book you only have a selection in your,
uh,
in your book,
of translated stories in the book.
Uh,
the volume,
uh,
consists of a prologue,
parts of which are included in my essay,
the,
in the case book about self portraits and then 12 stories.
Remember I talked about that number because if the pretended and was by
Serantes,
maybe he didn't include it because he didn't want the number 13.
Uh,
but any case,
there are 12 stories and these two that you see for marriage and the dog's
collar,
we are the end,
the c four,
Marriage Dot Columbia.
And that's the end of the volume.
The order of stories in such a volume is always a significant.
So to me it is significant that the volume should end with these two stories,
this interlocking stories too.
Now,
as we saw with her,
oh,
cakey not the Catalan bandage,
he ness,
they pass among their,
the,
the galleys later and then later a master puppeteer and Moni polio in,
uh,
[inaudible] Cervantes often paints a sympathetic portrait of criminal types.
At least he never paints one.
There is one side of the negative and he,
he seems to have a liking for these characters.
One reason may be that like Don Quixote,
who is also a delinquent as we now,
uh,
they represent or original ways of life different from mainstream society.
Uh,
hence more interesting and appealing from a literary point of view.
If you're good,
you're not interesting to literature for the most part.
So the criminal types are interesting because they are criminals and they are
different and they have different lives that are quite original.
We saw the same tendency in Velazquez,
Velazquez Paints,
dwarves and near criminals and all of that because they are interesting,
uh,
different,
also criminal life.
And this,
and this would go back to Sally.
Yes.
Could represent the,
the,
the origins of societal norms or how societal norms develop,
uh,
norms that,
that emerge out of the clash of instincts,
desires,
laws and so forth.
And this,
this is why the,
the,
uh,
the criminals are,
are interesting.
If you follow the law and all of that,
you're not very interesting.
The pension for criminal,
uh,
types found in the picaresque.
And he said,
Ron,
this is something that will become a staple of the novel,
especially,
uh,
the 19th century novel,
is,
uh,
people by criminals have all kinds of
interesting,
sometimes appealing criminals of all kinds like John Paul Jones and so forth.
So we moved to this,
uh,
stories,
the deceitful marriage [inaudible] and the dogs,
colloquial colloquium de Los Peros.
Now notice that these two stories,
one implanted into the other,
uh,
as it were,
follow the narrative device called the framed tail.
That is the Paler we,
the tail
a,
it's a device that goes back to the origins of storytelling and the thousand and
one nights,
for instance.
Now it allows this to finish his volume of stories with one of his cherished
infinitely receiving sequences.
Remember we've spoken about this infinity receding sequences,
one within the older,
within the other,
within the older,
I will often use the example of the uh,
of,
of the bill boy as I remember myself sitting in a barber chair surrounded by
mirrors and then see myself disappear in the distance or images of myself and
also the,
the kind of evaporated milk with a label with a,
with that has a depicted,
a kind of revolt and so forth and so on.
So this is what the device is a story within the story.
Okay.
They are like Chinese boxes,
wine inside the older it is a,
it is a form of closure.
If we're thinking of they close are,
they finished the book that denies closure as it were.
The volume is open ended but it's open ended sort of open unto itself.
There could be more and more and more and more stories down.
If you dug deeper into the stories,
uh,
there could be yet another story,
which indeed there is a one story that is virtual or postponed in the,
in the,
in,
in the second story,
the doctors called me because the,
the story of one of the dogs' lives,
it's not taught for,
this is what I mean.
MMM.
When I wrote an essay on this many years ago,
uh,
I called it,
the life of CPO,
uh,
saying that my essay was sort of like the telling of this life that was not told
in the story.
Now,
in the deceitful marriage,
marriage is deconstructed,
uh,
acid.
We're both us as a social institution and as a narrative tool,
uh,
we should read the story against the backdrop of all of the stories about
marriage that we have read in the quarter.
And also in the context of the pretended
in fact did the seed for a marriage is,
it's a story of surroundings that comes closest salaciousness to that contested
story that the pretend that that is,
this is the dirtiest of Savannah stories.
Uh,
uh,
if we pretend that Andy's not [inaudible] I'm sure you will agree with me and
you will agree more with me once you hear my,
my reading.
Oh,
um,
it's the funnier the protagonist is a proactive female Botero a female
protagonist like others in Cervantes.
Doto pay,
uh,
not say last or Aida who charts her own course and follows it with cunning.
And with the courage of course she is a prostitute,
but she is a proactive female protagonists of Serantes.
She dupes inside campus Campuzano uh,
luring him with her beauty and uh,
pretend that worth we could call it to with her house.
Notice the detail is,
I told you to look for details and said,
Lantis,
how does she newer the inside?
She has beautiful hands and that is the first thing that the inside notices when
he sees her,
uh,
this is sort of a fetish for hands and feet to eve.
Remember,
Dorothea were mostly,
uh,
as Stefania has a beautiful hands.
Uh,
she traps him into marrying her,
but then it turns out she was not the owner of the house.
Though the true proprietors come back and she's campers with the jewels with
which she thought he had a,
he had full her,
he thought that he had full her because he,
he if,
uh,
boasts that they're counterfeit anyway,
the jewels that she steals,
it turns out however,
that she had the last laugh because she had infected him with syphilis.
It kind of delayed action.
They need actual counter blow by which she wins the game.
It is clear that what is Stefania did was her emo,
her models operandi and that the inside was neither the first nor her last
victim.
The cousin so called cousin who's present at his wedding was obviously you're
her pimp.
Uh,
what not.
Obviously it's,
it's us and make things that obvious,
but it is there.
Uh,
who was this guy?
Well,
this guys are obviously her pimp.
Uh,
and this is a,
this is a routine that they use to,
uh,
to Ensnare,
guys like the inside a pile.
He of course thinks that he's also going to have a good time and that is going
to fool her because he's making plans to scamper and go back to war.
Uh,
once he has had enough of a good time.
What is of interest to mean?
The story,
uh,
house around this has manipulated literary conventions.
The story begins with a marriage virtually.
That is,
it begins where stories normally end and works backwards to undo a union that
never took place.
Legitimately it is a marriage into which they entered,
presumably without pretense or illusions.
She,
uh,
she tells him that she's no virgin and a t and she has had her life on this and
dad,
he doesn't care.
Uh,
and he of course,
uh,
is,
is not a wealthy aristocrat by any means.
And they know,
so they enter presumably without illusions into this marriage.
Uh,
but,
uh,
the marriage of course,
it's based on worst forms of deceit.
It also ends with an inversion at the end.
That should have been at,
it'd be beginning.
The man is fooled and the worn fleas in traditional stories,
it is the opposite.
The woman is full and the man,
the Guy Fleas,
marriages as we have seen throughout the semester are normally how stories end.
I repeat,
they bring closure to the action representing the restoration of order and the
continuation of the species here.
However,
instead of MTSS inverted the for the formula,
that's the story begins with a marriage as we have seen.
And I have said many times,
perhaps too many times throughout the semester,
and it's not a warning to you everything that happens before marriage is the
stuff of comedy instead of antisemitism that happens after marriage,
stuff of tragedy.
But here surely because their marriage is phony,
what follows is common call
on worse.
The marriage by the way,
would have been an old,
uh,
under Spanish law and even church,
kind of law,
uh,
had the insight suit as the Funnier,
for misrepresenting herself.
She was not the owner of the house and so forth,
but he could not sue her because he too had misrepresented his wealth,
the jewels or who come to fit.
Uh,
and he also had plans to quit the premises as soon as he could.
Now the end blend of all of these,
uh,
the seats is the house,
which should have on the country or normally provided the foundation of our
marriage.
It is in the house or they spent a brief period of matrimonial bliss.
This is the end ganja part that precedes the dissing Ganja legally.
And traditionally the house is the concrete sight of,
of marriage.
And,
uh,
and in,
in,
in Spanish,
the word for marriage where the word that is in the title of the story is
Casamento.
Casa means house in Spanish.
I liked the word gossip me and told his house,
I lie Anto from interior to lie in Spanish.
It's a,
it's a phony at the mall and you that I make up a,
it's also one of those soft things that language,
uh,
gifts the language makes,
do humor.
Uh,
and the word for wife in Spanish,
as you probably know,
this is pasta,
which is also the word for handcuffs.
I didn't invent the language and it is also a false in any case,
uh,
so,
the house is the emblem of this,
uh,
of this,
of his house gas sameon lie.
Uh,
the,
the plot of the deceitful or marriage is indeed very,
very disturbing because it leads to total disorder to a dissolution of the
social pact,
a social contract altogether.
It seems,
uh,
this is why I find it such,
such a disturbing story.
Husband and wife disappear.
They are not really husband and wife.
One never to be heard from again.
Stefania vanishes.
She has to vanish like the galley slaves because probably the authorities or
after her and he winds up in the,
uh,
in the hospital with a social disease for which most people never recovered.
Uh,
it is as if the story with his formal play of inversions is hinting not tragedy,
but at something perhaps worse if that is possible.
The disappearance of all bonds,
the unraveling of the discourse that hold human society together and organized.
This is what is hinted at by this very disturbing story.
Indeed.
What follows is the story of the inside Campuzano in the hospital and the
hallucination that leads him to write the next story,
the dog's Colloquy.
It is ironic in a way that I find more bitter than is normal instead of Lantis
that what leads to literary creation here is not just a social disease,
but the disease of love
called at the time syphilis was called at the time in Spanish,
El Mal Francis,
the French disease.
Uh,
I dunno why the Spanish always blame the French for everything having to do with
sex.
Um,
the law of madness,
uh,
of courtly love parts is literalized here.
They love madness is a love disease,
eh?
Literalize the venereal illness.
The dogs Colloquy is like a Stephanie,
us and the insights child.
It is the product of their deceit for marriage.
This is very,
this I find very disturbing suggestion.
So we move to the dog's Colloquy.
Okay,
let me begin by considering the names of the dogs,
the heroic Scipio CPM in Spanish and the picaresque better [inaudible].
So the two dogs,
historically,
there were two scenarios.
The one who took and destroyed Carthage and his son who destroyed the Spanish
down of Newman Sia and event on which Servantez based perhaps his most
successful play.
So he knew well about CPR,
but again,
sir is derived from Brigantine
right or fashion word,
no
better gun,
but the gun is a,
is a rogue rascal.
Um,
whereas of course a Scipio is a heroic name.
The name of a military commander.
Uh,
the two,
the two dogs,
uh,
make up a parent like Don Quixote on central.
If you think of it,
the sort of big arrest type Bergen Braganza and the military,
uh,
CPR,
a
CPL life,
the one not told,
it's suggested that could have been another key haughty,
but in a different key at Quixote in a canine key.
I said where it would be the,
uh,
a mock heroic dog's life.
We could,
uh,
we could call him.
It's just suggested,
uh,
now and science come from Sonos predicament.
Lincoln illness and creativity is a spoof,
as I have said,
of the Sig Lover Port able to compose poetry because of his,
of his condition is a,
this will become a romantic,
a trope only that here it is,
these illnesses dramatically and literally a newness of love of the lowest,
uh,
kind.
Uh,
remember that he,
he the only cure other than some potions and stuff,
he still let him sweat it out and just hospital,
uh,
on,
on some,
uh,
some survive,
but not,
not too many notice.
Also,
we the,
the ironic name of the hospital,
I don't know if you noticed that it's [inaudible] to Rex Hospital of the
resurrection.
Uh,
and this is out of,
through a kind of wrestle [inaudible] comes out after he has sweated out,
uh,
he's,
his syphilis or at least part of his,
uh,
syphilis
now,
uh,
Cervantes skirts here,
the supernatural in the story.
The idea that dogs can talk the supernatural never appears instead of antithesis
works.
Uh,
but,
uh,
he leaves open the here at the possibility that the dog,
the story of the dog stalking is merely a halogenation on the part of,
of Campuzano who's ill and in his illness and,
and fever,
he imagines this,
you've got to also be a literary roofs on the part of the insight.
I mean,
it is the character within the story,
uh,
who is making this up said run at this would say,
he wants to live in an ambiguous state.
The origin of his literary creation.
To me it is very suggestive.
I didn't know if you found it so that he falls asleep while his lawyer friend
called graduate in your translation.
Listen,
Seattle,
a lawyer,
he is a graduate in law.
Uh,
I find it very suggestive that the author falls asleep while Peralta is reading
his story.
I as well,
I mean,
it's also very significant that the reader is someone,
a lawyer trained to read text and ascertain their truthfulness.
This is sort of,
uh,
an ironic,
reading scene.
You know,
the lawyer reading this to,
to,
to tell whether it is true or not.
Uh,
now on one level it is,
this is a text belongs to the realm of dreams.
The fact that he's sleeping and it is as if the reader is tapping directly into
his dreams as he's sleeping it,
it occurs to me,
uh,
because it's author,
it's asleep when it's being read and another,
it is as if there is a gap between creator and the texts needed for the reader
to judge to judge it independently.
There is eastern sleep is no longer in control of the text.
The text is now in the hands of the reader and it is the,
for the reader to determine whether it is true or not.
This is why he is asleep.
Of course.
It's also a way of having him do something.
Well,
the other one reads the way would have been to have him go to the market or
something,
but I think this is but more interesting or suggested the fact he falls asleep.
I like to think of it as,
as I said,
the reader is tapping directly into subconscious because he's asleep
now.
Been asked that in a way is,
is stand in for us,
the readers.
He offers a literary judgment at the end,
we're announcing this story growed a,
they'll hardly believable and encouraging his friend,
uh,
to go ahead and write the next life notice in the context of my discussion of
the ending of like he hopped in the last lecture that life is here is the shape
of the story in life,
the life of Braganza and the next life is going to be the life of Cpr of CPO.
It is also of course forward in that the shape of the pickers that we saw when
we discuss the,
uh,
the figure of [inaudible] who has written his life in prison and so forth and so
on.
Now,
there is more than a hint to that.
The story that the insight tells or rights through the dog is an encoded
autobiography.
This is a picaresque autobiography in which the picker or pretends to be a dog.
It's very ingenious and inventive turn.
Uh,
also Rhonda says,
uh,
part,
why is it autobiographical?
Particularly because when he takes the manuscript from his,
uh,
pocket,
he takes her out of his,
said no send means is,
is Busan.
It's taking it out of his heart in a way.
So this is it.
This is a,
a suggests to me that this is inside Campuzano story,
but told deflected into the life of this,
uh,
of this dog.
It is,
it is very interesting that literature issues out of these tawdry living
conditions and figures literary Krish as he did in the case of Vanessa Samantha,
who wrote his his life while he was in prison.
And also in the case of Cervantes himself,
who's life,
if not quite as tawdry sometimes was like that when he was,
when he was a prisoner,
a captive in Algiers.
And the couple of times that when he was really in jail,
uh,
at,
in Spain for irregularities in his accounts when he was collecting,
uh,
for the,
Spanish armada and so forth.
So,
uh,
I think that this is a Sorento says,
take on the,
on the origins of modern literature.
Uh,
it,
it originates in these conditions and out of figures like lease.
Now the point is that,
uh,
that he's showing the virtual workings of the literary imagination,
which deflects the real and,
and the tawdry or the,
the CD life of the enzyme and deflect that into the life of the dog,
which has a slightly classical form because of the fables or dog speak and so
forth.
I mentioned in the text,
um,
now the uncertain origin of the dogs who could also be the transformed songs of
that,
which in that marvelous scene with sandwiches that I am sure you remember,
and that allude or hearkened back to [inaudible],
uh,
or they could have been simply dogs born,
where in the slaughterhouse of Seville,
Remember Seville is the,
the,
the capital of bigger sk life.
And this ladder,
there's a lot of house seems to be the capital within the capital of Bucharest
life.
But it also Sarandos is also leaving,
uh,
the origin of the story in,
in an air of indeterminacy,
uh,
sort of like Don Quixote's origins.
Uh,
I think that the significance of the ending of the story,
Eh,
again,
back to the infinitely receding sequences is that it brings about no closure at
all to the volume.
So we make a little digression digression here before we get towards the end of,
uh,
of,
of the lecture,
uh,
to discuss cafcass parable that I hope you read for today.
CAFCA 1883,
1924,
as we all know,
was a Czech author who wrote in German such masterpieces of the Metamorphosis
1915 that trial 1925,
the castle 1926 and when she presented a world ruled by arbitrary and mysterious
bureaucratic laws by which the characters seem to abide,
impelled by,
by obscure forces,
he never published this work which he ordered that he be destroyed upon his
death and wish that fortunately was not followed.
Uh,
I think that this brief text,
it's just a paragraph shows to what extent Cafca I think connected with the core
of sort of antithesis literary imagination,
which Advantis his notion and feel for a literary creativity.
The text is entitled the Truth About Sancho Panza and it says,
without making any boast of it sent Japan's I succeeded in the course of years
by feeding him a great number of romances of chivalry and adventure in the
evening and night hours you saw diverting from himself,
his demon whom he later called Don Quixote,
that this demon there upon set out on inhibited on the mattress exploits,
which however,
for the lack of a preordained object,
we should have been sent your bouncer himself,
how nobody the Fremont sent Japan's a reassignment.
Lee followed don Quixote in his crusades,
perhaps out of a sense of responsibility and out of them are great and edifying
entertainment to the end of his days.
That's the parable on the truth of central Buzzer.
So I think that calf guys turning Cervantes fiction upside down,
but within the spirit of Serantes,
uh,
by making central the inventor of the Quixote and following him around
afterwards,
the whole fiction comes out of sanctuary demon.
That is the demon of a common man.
Like those both got cancer.
Vantis like to invent the glass graduate for example,
is another common man was,
and also like other authors in Cervantes,
Sanchez creation gets out of hand and in and acquires,
uh,
alive,
overtone.
I think this is cafcass reading of surroundings.
I think it's a very profound reading even if it is oh,
perhaps to go cities.
So brief,
I also wish to mention
the board has story pmnr author of the Quixote,
which is one of the most famous stories by border hissing,
which as you remember,
uh,
these French,
poet minor poet,
decides to rewrite the Quixote,
not just rewrite the jihad.
They bought word by word as Cervantes had written it.
The idea being that it is much more difficult to write the hotel and 17th
centuries,
uh,
a Spanish,
especially by a French one by a Frenchman.
Donny was for Cervantes to write it in his own time and so forth.
This is a big literary joke on the part of,
of borders,
but at the same time bar has,
is unsettling the romantic notion of the link between creator and,
and work.
Uh,
and uh,
when she shows he cannot completely unsettled it because pmnr dies
because of the effort it took to do this,
which of course you could never finish.
It's an impossible task that he sets for himself.
Uh,
bought his,
was also reacting in 1939 when he wrote the story to what he considered to be
sort of Prato fascist readings of the Quixote by Spanish colors.
Remember the Spanish civil war,
it's just over and the promotion of,
of East bunny.
Dot.
The Spanish snus and so forth.
And he's trying to show that,
uh,
Cervantes a great creation,
it belong to any single language when any single,
uh,
a national,
tradition,
but that it can be potentially can be written or rewritten by anyone.
Also he is underlining something that he himself set with,
with Cervantes Ian,
uh,
self deprecation that once you write something that is good,
it doesn't belong to you anymore.
It belongs to the tradition.
And so this is what he's saying.
They around this creation has escaped him because he's now belongs to the
tradition,
not to sit around this.
This is something that border has set.
Now let us finish by talking a bit of our caravan.
This is death.
Going back to the beginning of today's class,
uh,
I think that said,
rant is identified with a desk.
Don't be haughty and alone.
So,
uh,
know I think that there is an identification with,
with them,
uh,
because he feels that life us fiction has to come to an end,
and a form of truth.
Once we reached on the brink of death,
it is a form of truth for which ironically,
literature has prepared him through the understanding of destined Ganja.
Cervantes seems to be saying that he liked Don Quixote's renouncing a life of
make belief.
So what,
so what is the sense of the novel's ending?
Perhaps it is the feeling of sadness,
of regret,
that the book,
that madness,
the entertainment and the fund have to come to an end.
Like everything else,
it is not so much a sense.
You're just not so much sense as meaning as a sense,
as feeling,
uh,
not saying Ddo,
as a significant [inaudible] was us in the sense when our morning or uses the
word sent Demian the tragic sense of life.
So this is the sense of the ending of the Quixote.
It is a sense of,
of,
of sadness,
uh,
redolent with potential meaning for additional meanings that we cannot decipher
altogether.
Now,
the,
in the,
in the prologue lipid see lists,
which is sort of antithesis farewell.
He,
he presents himself as a man.
We signed to his impending death and content with his accomplishments.
Going back to what Darren has said in the quote at the very beginning of my
lecture.
Uh,
the taxi Serrano,
his farewell,
the dedication to the policies,
uh,
the dedication,
not the prologue or they must have been contemporaneous contemporary to each
other was April 19th,
16th,
the dedication that is four days before his death,
he says that he has,
uh,
was given the extreme unction,
which is,
you know,
the last rites in the Catholic,
uh,
a church.
And,
and then,
uh,
he,
writes the following,
uh,
oh boy.
I can have,
but Howard here,
I do want to,
um,
yes.
So I am going to read it.
It takes five minutes in Spanish and then I'm going to read it in English.
Apologies to those who cannot follow in Spanish because I'm going to say
something about the rhythm of the pros.
And I want you to do here it
[inaudible] [inaudible] the alternative dos Amigos,
see Jordan [inaudible]?
Yes.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] most binos San Te.
Can we say [inaudible]?
Did I?
Yeah,
they say,
or they'll consider those young [inaudible] bosses cannot be [inaudible] if
they're amorously ego.
So they're not bored.
Rica,
we went to the empty barrel.
Val [inaudible] and [inaudible] Ballona Nida e Eh,
constraints has a wireless,
but it other cannot [inaudible] I won't Lau Lau.
Alona
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] is Tasha [inaudible] issue.
My head started the mass.
Manos say we will not [inaudible] that come in and [inaudible] I look
[inaudible].
They'll say
[inaudible] [inaudible] I paint.
I said
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] eh,
cc [inaudible] Manco Sano it'll,
if I'm also toto [inaudible] Moses,
your came done to pass your wheel grounding [inaudible] but as your
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Joseph
[inaudible] [inaudible] Musashi meaning Guna that I think [inaudible] said
[inaudible] [inaudible] felt that the Camino he showed us,
he has to be most [inaudible].
That's he can pass for us in
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] are they,
how are they better?
Eh,
the better.
I told him,
even in the [inaudible],
maybe that's it.
[inaudible] the last Fmri this and they'd be full of stuff.
I started that I call
[inaudible] [inaudible] and [inaudible] sediment,
but normally
[inaudible] [inaudible] were some of the sent me.
I'm going to throw
[inaudible] [inaudible] they're going into my Madrid.
You understand how to throw,
I'll say,
oh yeah,
look and said e.
Dot.
Denise,
who says show up and
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] for the said Y'all send me off for the said
be Goss water.
[inaudible] water again.
Yeah,
that little gang.
Oh Gosh.
You're going to be blue my by the community.
Go now.
You just better know some thoughts
then over in the dark.
You sat him down to London.
Hello dear.
Look at him in front of the thoughts.
You know,
can say [inaudible] either y'all could osseous [inaudible] so if you don't have
to go see house,
I'm egos.
Can you want me to,
we moved into,
just say I'm debater,
which goes in English.
I hope we thought an interruption like the one we had before.
Uh,
you catch the setting there going in.
He's going into,
uh,
into Madrid.
Where the court,
because this is what he,
it so happened dearest reader,
us to friends and I were coming from the famous down over skeevy us,
which is where his wife was from,
famous for a thousand reasons,
one of them being its illustrious families and another is even more illustrious
wines that I perceive someone behind me sparing his mount on in a great hurry.
He apparently wanted to overtake us and soon made that clear by calling out for
us not to start on.
So urgently we waited for him and on a,
she has came up,
came a drab student drive because he came dressed all in rustic brown with
leggings,
round toed shoes,
a sword in a cheque scabbard and a starch lace color.
With this matching ties.
The fact of the matter is that he only had two of these ties to hold it on,
so every other minute the color kept falling over to one side and he was a great
pace to keep it straight catching up to us.
He said she was Sarah's must be on your way to court to obtain some office or
benefits from his most illustrious grace of Toradol and his majesty themselves
are downloads there judging by the hairy with which are tr with which you are
traveling since even my ass,
judging by the hurdles which are traveling,
uh,
my ass,
which has been praised than once from her
speed.
Couldn't catch two.
You do this.
One of my companions replied,
it's the fault of Senora Miguel disadvantages.
Nag,
which is somewhat long,
stepping scarcely had the student heard the names to the month is when needs is
mounted from his back animal sending his Saddleback's flying in one direction
and Israelis in another,
he traveled so completely outfitted and rushed up to me seizing my left hand and
say,
yes,
this is the complete cripple,
the completely famous and comic writer.
And lastly,
the delight of the muses.
I who is our shortest space of time.
So search great companies in my praise felt it would have been this courteous
not to respond to them.
And so embracing him around the neck whereby I destroyed his color altogether.
I said to him,
that is an error into which many of my unit uninformed admirers or fallen.
I,
sir,
I'm set around this but not the delight of the muses or any other foolish things
that you mentioned.
Round up your ass bumped up our,
let's pass the brief remainder of our journey in pleasant conversation the
obliging students did.
The student did just that.
We reign in slightly and then resumed our trip,
but a more leisurely pace as we traveled we talked about are about my illness
and the good student immediately diagnosed me a helpless case saying this Dicks,
the stick,
this is drop seen,
curable.
Even if you were to drink all the waters of the ocean made sweet,
so you noticed that Advantis sir,
you should limit your drinking and don't forget to eat for thereby you will
recover without any other medicine.
That's what many have told me.
I replied,
but I just can't give up the pleasure of drinking all I want for it almost seems
I was born to it.
My life's race is slowing at the rate of my pulse and by this Sunday at the
latest it will be complete.
It will complete its course and within my life user have made my acquaintance at
a difficult moment who are there isn't enough time left to express my gratitude
for the goodwill you've shown me at this point.
We arrived at the Toledo bridge where I crossed into the city and he wrote off
to enter by the Segovia road.
I said,
what may be said of this incident,
fame would take care to report it.
My friends will take pleasure in telling it and I even more pleasure in hearing
it.
Once again,
we embraced each other.
He's spirit mount and left me just as ill at ease as he was in trying to be a
gentleman on that ass.
He had afforded my pen a greater opportunity to be witty,
but you can always make one moment but you can have another at time it come.
Perhaps when I shall tie up this broken thread and say what I fail to hear and
what would have been fitting good by humor.
Goodbye wit goodbye.
Merry friends for a com dying for I am dying and hope to see you soon.
Happy in the life to come
here.
We find the same set of antiques of the key hope their products.
Uh,
these are the five points that I want to make.
That one,
the prologue
as dialogue as in part one and throughout savant,
this is work.
Instead of an expository priest,
a piece in the first person,
he needs to create an alert to tell the story of his own self.
Why do these dialogues reflect those going on in his own mind
that do reflect he's ironic stance before his own sense of self and beef before
his own sense of the truth.
Because it is a sort of this perspective is that we have seen true
here are so many times in the cohort that we have another student with hilarious
details about his clothing.
Uh,
students are seekers of knowledge readers,
which are of great interest to serve Lantus.
As we all know the details I sold details.
Uh,
instead of Andis are revealing of character of personality.
This is a way,
a very economical way of talking about this guy's personality by showing,
uh,
he's vanity with all of his clothes that he's wearing city.
The scene takes place on the road,
symbol of time and of life as in the Quixote for.
And I think this is the subtlest and this is why I wanted you to hear it in my
uninterrupted reading in Spanish,
the rhythm of,
of pros,
I don't know if the story itself seems to echo that of the trotting horses,
this dropping of the horses and the various spaces that the horses follow,
our marketing time and time.
It's fleeting.
Miss is the theme of these piece lives,
race and life's journey,
coalesce as death approaches and is mark by the,
by the trotting of the horses and by the rhythm of the prose,
five Cervantes deals.
Ironically with his late fame,
which comes when he's near death,
uh,
it's something out of rhythm because now it is of little constellation or profit
for him.
Uh,
so we have here the same self deprecating Cervantes said we have learned to
love.
Now it is in that same spirit that I ask him or wherever he happens to be.
And I asked you,
uh,
forgiveness for my own shortcomings in commenting his work.
Thank you very much.